oh that was a very touching introduction
thank you Tom this really is you know I
do think that everything happens for a
reason and it is a crazy but fortuitous
day for me it truly is a full-circle
moment I was literally in your seat not
just 20 years ago but even last week so
I have a huge appreciation for the power
of this speaker series and it really is
an honor to participate in it before I
give my talk two quick caveats the first
is is that today we're going to be
talking about building venture scalable
businesses or billion-dollar businesses
and I want to say that that is just one
slice of entrepreneurship it is an
important slice but it is a narrow slice
and I want to caveat this by saying that
your first job if you feel the calling
of entrepreneurship is to reflect within
about what is authentically right for
you and then to curry the resources
talent and capital to get your mission
to be realized and if that can't align
with the venture-backed model you can do
amazing things but every company and
every venture is different and the
second thing I just want to say is is
that my intention here is to really
distill the nuggets of insight that I've
collected along the way over the 20
years since I was in your seat as a
Stanford student and to share those
nuggets and every now and then you'll
pick out pick a nugget of insight that
will come to you in life to try to
distill those for you for anybody who's
going down this path and my defining
professional work experience was in
venture capital and so that is why this
talk is going to be about building
billion-dollar businesses okay so we're
going to be talking about building these
grand scale types of businesses okay and
so with that let me first give a some
further details about Who I am
Tom's introduction was fantastic I as as
I said I graduated from Stanford with
the bachelors in engineering and a
master's in industrial engineering when
I was at Stanford one of my hallmark
experiences was as a Mayfield fellow and
I worked at a company as an intern at a
startup called extensity that went
public I then worked at McKinsey in San
Francisco and then at another startup
with other Mayfield Fellows called zap
tlit that raised a hundred million
dollars in venture capital but then
ultimately failed but my canonical work
experience was as a venture capitalist
at DFJ in Menlo Park
so at dfj we funded and I got to see
companies grow like Skype Tesla Baidu
SpaceX so some phenomenal companies from
the sidelines the one company that I
championed when I was at the FJ was a
company called justin.tv which Draper
associates led an investment into that
became twitch that get that was acquired
for just shy of a billion dollars by
Amazon so that was my first unicorn
experience and then dfj became the
anchor investor in the accelerator that
I now run called Alchemist so Alchemist
is backed by a bunch of VCS and other
reputable institutions and we write
small checks into a lot of companies a
year we give typically thirty six
thousand dollars to 70 startups a year
and we were fortunate enough to be rated
the top accelerator in 2016 by CB
insights based on how much money our
companies raised and we generally
reviewed as one of the top overall
accelerators we focus on any startups
that monetize from enterprises and I
mention that because we have seen the
model of building startups on that
venture back path we've had 137
companies close capital they've raised
almost a billion dollars and we've had
34 acquisitions and these are some of
our graduates some of whom have also
been detail speakers in the class but we
have many companies that are emerging
out of alchemists that have literally
raised over a hundred million dollars in
capital and that are on that path of
becoming a billion-dollar a unicorn
based startup and so with that that is
the experience that I have to inform the
talk today and the first thing that I
want to you guys to understand is you
know in good whenever we teach the
spirit of entrepreneurship we start from
within but then we also teach good
classic customer development and design
thinking and when you're starting that
when you're looking at these models I
want you to also understand the
incentives and the motivations of of the
the venture capitalists that are
providing the fuel
that drives this specific type of
entrepreneurship and it is a very
powerful type of entrepreneur that we
remember Tom would use but this the the
industry venture capital is a powerhouse
of an industry it's just 0.2 percent of
our GDP and it's responsible for
creating companies that are responsible
for over a fifth of the economy so it is
a powerhouse of an industry but it's a
very idiosyncratic industry because
literally of the 10,000 startups that
get produced a year only 10 are
responsible for 97% of the returns and
so if you if you grok that further as a
venture capitalist if you are have a
fund it is very difficult for that fund
to economically survive unless that fund
is able to back companies that become
worth a billion dollars and these are
famously called from former ETL speaker
Eileen Lee unicorns I love that name but
also there's an issue with that name
because they aren't fictitious they
actually exist and part of our intention
with this class is to demystify these
unicorns as being real people who have
flaws just like everybody else but build
big companies and part of what I want to
do today is just to unlock some of the
hidden dynamics of how to build these
billion-dollar unicorns but if you if
you are a venture capitalist and you
have a billion dollar fund you're
getting that money from others and your
job is to pay that money back ok so if
you think about that if your goal is to
pay back a billion dollars that means
and if you assume that a venture capital
fund can own 20% of a company and you
know if you if they owned too much it
creates incentives problems with the
entrepreneurs that means to pay back a
billion dollars you need to have five
companies in your portfolio that become
worth a billion dollars
does that make sense and that's just to
pay back the fund 1x to pay back the
fund three times to make money you have
to have 15 unicorns and and so returning
a fund can be like captured captioning
catching lightning in a bottle and and
and the big issue is is that
historically there's only around 25
companies that get created every year
that become worth even at least just
half a billion
or above okay and so that is the nut of
trying to figure out how to crack the
venture capital industry as a venture
capitalist in some senses you are a
unicorn hunter if you do not fund a
company that becomes worth that amount
it is very difficult if you have a
certain fund of a certain size to stay
economically viable okay and so with
that we're gonna talk today about are
there any secrets around building
companies that become worth a billion
dollars or building these venture
scalable businesses and the key insight
here really is comes is distilled down
from the Archimedes quote you know
Archimedes famously said that if you
give me a lever long enough and a
fulcrum on which to place it I can move
the earth and the the notion there is is
that if you architect a system in the
right way for the same amount of effort
you can have a disproportionate return
you know former ETL speaker Ben Horowitz
who's a famous venture capitalist at
Andreessen Horowitz he said this I think
in another way where he basically says
it takes as much work to start a
mediocre business as it does to start a
big business so you might as well go big
you know I can assure you that if you
are not succeeding as an entrepreneur
you're not working any less okay you're
working as hard if not harder to get by
so if you're gonna go down the path of
entrepreneurship you will be working
hard and if you're going to be working
hard and you have a mission that you
care about part of the beauty of the
opportunity that exists if you do align
with venture capital is is that if you
go big in some ways more resources can
be thrown at you to solve that problem
and so right now then what I want to
discuss is how what are the what is the
architecture that you can do to sort of
invoke that Archimedes principle to
create these disproportionate returns
and the key insight here is to go from
zero to hero you need to walk
exponentially as opposed to linearly so
we all know the difference between
linear and exponential this is Stanford
I know this is Silicon Valley but if I'm
walking linearly it's just one two
three four right if I walk exponentially
it's one two four eight sixteen okay and
you know if you're going from a million
dollar valuation today to a billion
dollar valuation in ten years what that
means is that you need to grow a
thousand x in ten years to grow a
thousand x in ten years that means you
need to grow 10x three times does that
make sense so 10x every three years to
grow 10x every three years you need to
triple every year and a half or double
roughly every 12 months
I know it's basic math but just just
rockin that or just internalizing that
will make a lot of other things clearer
about how the dynamics of Silicon Valley
work and so just to make this graphical
this is the growth of the internet from
the 60s to the 2000s okay and it looks
fairly linear but it's posted on a
logarithmic scale but if you're the
Internet it looks like things just grew
at a normal pace you know they just grew
linearly but if I shift that scale from
a logarithmic scale to a linear scale
that same data looks like this and
suddenly it looks like something drastic
happened in the late 90s there was an e
in the curve and everything suddenly
changed but the reality was is that the
Internet the dynamics of how the
internet was growing was steady it was
just architected a way to grow
multiplicatively and we who experienced
the world linearly felt it as this big
shift that happened in the late 90s and
so we've already sort of gone over the
math of this but basically we need to
sort of double every year to get to that
billion dollar outcome in ten years or
if you want to do in a short period of
time you have to grow even quicker okay
and we all understood I think the
difference between different growth
rates so now then the question becomes
so Ravi what are these architects or
these mechanisms these drivers to
architect something for multiplicative
growth and I'm gonna we're gonna talk
about a few but the overriding principle
that I want you to understand is
thinking about how you set things up so
that there's positive reinforcement
loops so that every action you take has
a multiplicative effect and not just a
linear effect so
that the output is not a linear function
of the input but it's a multiplicative
output and so let me make this clear so
we're gonna start with the first a first
driver which is just simply gross
margins gross margins is just the
revenue minus the car the gross costs of
producing an item so let's say that I am
selling a cookie okay and it costs me 50
cents to make a cookie and I know all
those ETL students are really hungry
after they hear those lectures and so I
camp out outside of class episode of
Huang and my intention is to sell you a
cookie and if I sell you that cookie for
$1 okay my gross margins are 50 cents I
sell you the cookie for dollar cost me
50 cents to make I make 50 Cent's of
profit which means that how many cookies
can I make next one cookie okay I sell
that other cookie for $1 I make 50 cents
of profit and I can make one more cookie
so at 50 cents or a 50% margin my slope
is zero does that make sense I am
basically just making one cookie every
every cycle okay if I have the insight
to say you know what I'm not going to
target the Stanford students I'm gonna
go to a faculty club that's where they
have the money and I'm gonna charge a
buck 50 for that for that cookie
suddenly just by shifting the price up
to a dollar 50 my margins go from 50
percent to 67 percent but I sell that
cookie for a dollar 50 at the Faculty
Club it cost me 50 cents to make I make
a dollar of profit which means how many
cookies can I make I can make two
cookies okay and if I sell both of those
two cookies for a buck 50 each it's
three dollars it cost me a dollar to
make I have two dollars in profit which
means I can make four cookies okay so
just by doing that subtle shift of
having the gross margins go from 50
percent to 67 percent I'm suddenly on a
multiplicative path okay does that make
sense and at 75 then let's say if you
know what you feel like you know it's
not the Faculty Club it's the Stanford
mall that's where the real money is all
the venture capitalists go and they shop
there I'm gonna go to the Stanford mall
and sell that cookie for $2
and it only cost me 50 cents suddenly I
make 75% margins or a buck 50 I sell one
cookie for 50 cents for two dollars I
make a dollar 50 a profit
I can then produce three cookies if I
sell those three cookies for $2 each
that's six dollars it cost me two
dollars I make four dollars of profit
and then I keep going up okay and so 75%
then gets us up this got this magic
growth clip of 3x I can start growing 3x
at 75% and so one of the golden rules by
the way is is that if you do not want to
raise venture capital but you're like I
do want to build a billion-dollar
business if you can have your margins be
75% or higher and if you can bill up
front if you can have people pay you
before you have to build the product so
if you can have people prepay for a year
or Spotify before you deliver the
service or prepay for a magazine then
you can be customer funded and put
yourself on that 3x growth curve - just
to keep hitting things okay this is why
venture capitalists love software
because the costs as we increase these
margins our growth rates become even
more absurd and if you think about
what's with software the cost of doing a
Google search the the gross costs are
just the energy of that server
it's basically infinite it's basically
nothing and this is why VCS hate
hardware I mean just to oversimplify I
don't want to speak for all aventure
capitalists but Hardware requires
capital you know you have to put in
money your gross margins are lower you
need to worry about distribution and all
these other things okay and so these are
some questions that I would ask if I was
a venture capitalist and that I would
also also want to arm you to understand
if you're a founder building a business
that's seeking venture capital or just
trying to build a big business is
understand what your gross margins are
if you're building hardware understand
what your bill of materials are and if
you are building something that's going
to be hardware like then you need to be
able to answer the question of how do
you finance the business to cover your
cost of goods and that's a separate
discussion that we can have later does
that make sense so that's lesson one is
gross margins
the next thing that I think is a source
and these are just sources of
multiplicative growth of exponential
growth they exist everywhere everywhere
you see these positive reinforcing loops
where the input can lead to an a
multiplicative output pay attention but
the other thing is technology and this
is why investors love to fund companies
that are built on new tech because tech
is inherently exponential in how it
grows this is the classic Kurzweil graph
on Moore's Law and I know we have a
sophisticated audience here Moore's law
is just this notion that the density of
transistors doubles every year and a
half for the same price point
effectively you everybody knows this
experientially when you go and you buy
your next smartphone it seems like it
can do everything so much more than it
could a year and a half ago and that
this this trend has held true since the
early 1900s the technology grows
naturally on a multiplicative curve
because the outputs of technology are
the become the inputs to drive the next
generation of technology we use the
Intel chips to build the computers that
design the next Intel chips if that
makes sense so the outputs become the
inputs and it naturally has an
exponential curve you see this all over
technology this is the growth of the
internet which we had before which is
doubling every 12 months this is
magnetic data storage which doubles
every 15 months but the core essence
here is is that technology is an
invitation it's an opportunity to take
to really enter into a market with a
weapon that might be creating a new
opportunity that you didn't have before
and so I would say actually the
essential question that venture
capitalists are looking for especially
what I've seen from the top-tier venture
capitalists is answering the question of
why now what technologically exists now
in your business that didn't exist
before that allows your business to to
succeed and so the essence of that is
what you know why couldn't this business
have been done three years ago and you
should have an answer to that if it
technologically could have been done
three years ago or five years ago it's
very hard oftentimes for somebody to
believe that just no one
of the other six billion people in the
world just didn't have the idea what's
more likely is that somebody tried the
idea and it failed for a REIT for other
reasons but if there was a technological
reason why your business couldn't have
existed before then that is credible
then it sort of makes sense that nobody
could have could have done it until now
so answering that why now question is a
very powerful one for both VCS and
entrepreneurs and again you know we
talked about exponential curves but
really exponential curves are just what
we call s curves where you're having
some technology that then becomes more
mainstream and then it gets replaced by
another exbest curve and the cascading
of those becomes this exponential curve
so a couple questions then that you
should think about if you're a founder
or that you might be be ready to be
asked if you go and present in front of
an investor is if you are gonna argue
that you're writing on some new
technology or you're developing a core
new technology as part of your offering
they'll be prepared to answer is this
technology advantage 10x better than the
alternative the reason why investors
will ask you for 10x is because just
secularly with Moore's law
everything doubles every 18 months so at
least with the 10x advantage you have
three 18-month doubling periods of a
buffer or around for years you know of a
buffer if you have less than 10x the
world that's gonna catch up to you
anyways so so think about if it's
something significant the other
questions that I would ask is that if I
was a customer and I was going to
evaluate you what metrics would I use to
assess you versus the alternatives and
how would you fare on those and if it's
and if the advantage of something
algorithmic think about what the
trade-off is are you sacrificing speed
for quality or something else you don't
also need to do it something that is
just purely technological you know the
iPhone was really the birthplace of so
many great companies like uber Spotify
Instagram that technically really
weren't building the chord disruption
they were riding on the wave of the
iPhone and that also is a fantastic is
if you can ride an existing platform
that is newly existing that just came
that just came out that also can create
huge benefits and be well received but
then just be prepared to answer why
you're gonna out
cute everybody else and you can say hey
we're using this new technology platform
but we're gonna out execute everybody
else for for these reasons I would say
that this is it's going to be a very fun
time if you to be a entrepreneur right
now because because of the acceleration
of Moore's law and because of how quick
technology is expanding we are going to
see 20,000 years of historical progress
is going to be the equivalent what's
gonna happen in the next hundred years
or in the in this century so if you just
extrapolate Moore's law going forward
there are some intimidatingly amazing
implications the first is is that you
know we achieve the capability of a
human brain for about a thousand dollars
by the time most of you by the 2023 when
most of you I guess will be 21 in this
in this class when you guys went you
know if you're a Stanford student today
by the time you're 37 we'll have the
capability of a human brain for a penny
and by the time you're in your late 40s
it will have the human races capability
for a thousand dollars and by the time
you're near 50s it'll be the whole human
race for a penny and so if you can grok
your mind to think exponentially to
think about where the puck is headed and
resist our natural tendency to
extrapolate the future from the linear
past there's so many opportunities
there's so much power in democratized
commoditized technology to take on all
the you know very very deep deep
problems that the world is facing so
that's technology as a source of
multiplicative growth and the final one
and I do want to make sure that we have
enough time for Q&A so the you know a
final one to touch upon I would say is
network effects which I know is sort of
a buzzy term that everybody talks about
these days but everybody understands
what a network effective a network
effect is something where a product
becomes more valuable as its scales its
users so as the volume of a product
which is an amazing thing
so usually as you scale volume quality
suffers you know as you get bigger you
worry that you're going to be delivering
less quality but if you build a business
that has Network effects
the opposite holds true as you get
bigger you deliver more value the
classic example of this is Skype or
whatsapp or any communication tool so if
if if there is only if I tell everybody
right now that hey I just built Raavi
app it's exactly like whatsapp it's
technically identical everybody should
use it nobody's gonna join Ravi app even
though I'm technically identical to
whatsapp because the network is on
whatsapp and the value is the network so
or if for example with Skype if there is
only one person on skype how many you
can make zero calls if there's two
people you can make one call if there's
three you can make three if there's four
you can make six every extra node that
gets added to the network increases the
number of connections and that's
generally referred to as Metcalfe's law
where the value of a communication
platform is a proxy to the square of the
nodes okay and so that's why
communication driven platforms like
Skype or whatsapp can be incredibly
powerful others have calculated the
value not just as the square of the
nodes but also as an exponential as a 2
to the N value based on the permutations
of the subgroups so if you look at the
value of Facebook based on all the
multitude of subgroups gap that can
emerge you get an even greater aunt a
greater response but the idea here is is
that if you build a business with
network effects every single additional
node creates more value for each
individual user and just to show you how
powerful this is if you look at Facebook
this is Facebook and it is impressive
how quickly Facebook grew so Facebook
grew at an incompressible I know that
you see there at the bottom but what's
even more impressive is the green dots
are their revenue and and the line next
to the green dots is a proxy of
Metcalfe's law that you know that
exponential growth that we were showing
so as impressive as their user growth
was it was even more impressive that
their revenue was growing exponentially
because of the network effects that are
inherent in a social network to
juxtapose that there's other great
companies that were great phenomenon
this is Angry Birds you guys know Angry
Birds right Angry Birds is a
single-player mode game phenomenon so if
I'm playing Angry Birds that does not
increase the value of your Angry Birds
experience it is your Angry Birds
experience does not increase with the
volume of the users and so Angry Birds
was amazing but it was completely linear
in terms of its revenue was just a
function of how many people downloaded
it it didn't become more valuable at
scale okay so thinking about how you can
build businesses with network effects
can also be very powerful and these
again occur really whenever there's a
positive feedback loop that can be
communication like Skype or whatsapp or
any social network that we've talked
about it can be a market place so you
know Craigslist or Ebay orphan are
examples of really hard businesses to
displace even though the technology is
very very basic because there's
liquidity of buyers and sellers together
on this common marketplace or it can be
a platform like the Apple operating
system where developers are building on
top of every developer that adds to
Apple's operating system extends the
functionality of the operating system
which then also creates more value for
valuable value for everybody that's
involved and so there's a type of
marketplace that happens with platforms
it's no but and and I should say you
know I was sort of speaking
disparagingly about hardware a few
minutes ago okay and you might say you
know hardware so so bad why do you have
all these beautiful software businesses
like Google that spent 3.2 billion
dollars on nest which is a hardware
device for the home or Facebook which
spent over 2 billion dollars for oculus
which is these hardware devices why is
hardware so disparaged if in fact these
companies beautiful software business
models are spending a lot of money for
them and I would argue it's because
Facebook you know is buying oculus
because
they don't want to be beholden to Apple
which is the hardware platform that they
are underneath because every time
somebody downloads a Facebook app for
your iPhone that becomes another user
that another platform can use for for
themselves so they may lose Facebook
users to other platforms that they're
trying to compete with and so ultimately
they're beholden to the underlying
platform which is what they want to own
so I would argue that's why they went
out to buy our so so the saving grace
here is what I want to say is is that
these platforms or network effects can
be incredibly powerful and they can
override even many of the other things
that I was discussing before and it's no
coincidence then that you know the the
four of the tech companies that became
worth the trillion dollars all have
network effects that play
Amazon's one of the biggest marketplaces
Apple has an operating system it has a
communication driven tools and
marketplaces all of these a exists
because for a reason and there's a
reason why that drove such huge huge
growth but I also want to say that
there's a bunch of so these are some of
the questions that you should be ready
to answer if you are a founder and
you're you're seeking a venture
capitalist who's trying to rule you in
or out as a unicorn they may ask a
question of you know let's say you
convinced them that your idea is a good
idea they'll say well if you prove out
your market if you prove out that what
you're doing is great and the competitor
creates a feature identical ripoff of
your product why would a new customer
still choose you and really what they're
asking is art do you have any network
effects you know just like nobody would
use Rubby app even if it's technically
identical because it's not about the
technology it's about the network
they're asking is there a long term
differentiation that you have besides
just the short term differentiation they
may ask DVR offering as a product or a
platform and again the platform it's is
their strategic value and the customer
beyond just the initial service you
provide and I'll you know think about if
you're if you want to focus on
monetization engagement or growth if
you're building something that has
Network effects it may be important to
focus on the long term game of growth or
engagement first
I want to end though by with with a note
about you know there are a lot of
companies that have Network effects that
don't become a trillion dollar company
or you know I think we're gonna be
ending we were - we started talking
about billion-dollar businesses let me
know and by talking about true in dollar
businesses okay so we had those four
examples Apple Amazon Microsoft and
Google or alphabet that are now trillion
dollar companies and there are a lot of
companies that that have you know there
are a lot of companies that have a lot
of smart minds that can learn all
everything that I'm saying and hire the
best smartest minds and don't become
trillion-dollar companies and I think
one thing that's hard to argue with this
is that all four of those companies not
besides just having and going after
network effects they all and this is
informed from a piece of deeper analysis
that Jeff Moore did about five years ago
on Apple and Amazon but they all four of
those companies had founders at the helm
as CEOs when they were publicly traded
companies for a long period of time and
I think that is not a coincidence okay
because there is something about a
founder that has the earned authority of
its employees and and its constituents
and it's stakeholders that can move
companies in directions that even the
smartest minds can't and there's
something about the founder experience
of starting from zero to one where you
go through your own journey of getting
knocked down and knowing who you are and
being able to actually get in touch with
that core in inviolable spirit that
exists in bad times are good and this is
sort of a time of reflection it's sort
of a time of really getting actually in
time in touch with that spirit that
becomes an indomitable power even when
you become famous and big and really
these companies aren't just companies
these are companies that build other
companies and and and and and I think
that's you know if you think about how
Apple has moved from a desktop company
to all these becoming the biggest music
company the biggest phone companies now
the biggest payments company or how
Amazon went from an online book store to
the biggest utility cloud computing
company now the biggest home AI company
that is now
a simple linear academic map there is
something else going on and what I want
you to understand is that the essence of
all this there is an entrepreneur behind
these great big fictitious seeming
companies that are unicorns or trillion
corns okay
that that is the indomitable spirit that
is impossible to replicate or copy and
so really the lesson that I would have
for you today is to get in touch with
what that means for you because you
anybody can copy your technology nobody
can copy you and so don't worry about
trying to be somebody else just get in
touch with what your best self is and
then curry the resources around you to
have that vision be realized and all of
you founders are heroes in that in that
sense so thank you we have about 10
minutes so I just want to make sure that
we had enough time for for questions and
thank you all for participating on this
very special and interesting day so I
will open it up for questions this is
like entrepreneurship no risk no reward
you have to raise your hand to ask yes
back there so I was wondering you were
talking about how
to return exponential growth in the next
century there are some people who think
Moore's law of slowing down that we're
getting like transistor Saturday to
school so you think that we're still
going to be able to maintain that
sensation
innovation without like yes this is a
great question the question as I was
saying that Moore's law looks like it's
it's it's gonna keep continuing but
there's a lot of people that are arguing
that Moore's law is going to hit its
limits because of a variety of reasons
including the heat density of
transistors hitting certain physical
limits and so forth I think that's
actually a good example of the s-curves
cascading so Moore's law is that
exponential curve and if you'd noticed
that example that I showed of Moore's
Law starting back in the early 1900's
those weren't electric transistors in
the early 1900 those were sometimes
physical gates that were the original
switches and I do think that transistors
as semiconductor transistors as we know
it may hit physical limits but I think
there'll be a new paradigm that may
replace those so whether that's quantum
computing or some other variant that
will allow us to shift that thing
forward I do think that there that is
what historically has held true so in my
opinion it's not it's the I wouldn't
conflate Moore's law with transistors
transistors is one technology s-curve
and Moore's laws of cascading of s
curves that oh I'm gonna call it so Tina
Seelig I'm very honored to have Tina
here you know we can have all of those
things in place at the beginning when
they're conceptualizing their company or
these things
so the question from Tina is there's a
founding entrepreneur need have all
these things in place when they're
starting their company or is this
something that can evolve over time you
do not need to have all of these things
when you are starting a company so the
the I think the irony of the path of
entrepreneurs of entrepreneurship is is
that it is this by focal exercise where
in the beginning probably the most
important thing is is is focusing the
the there's I think the hardest thing
when you're starting out as an
entrepreneurs is that the worst decision
can sometimes be indecision
most of the decisions are going to be
very gray and blurred and if you
overwhelm yourself with too many things
it can be paralyzing and so I do think
that Tina's question and underneath that
is a good lesson which is I don't want
this to or paralyze the
entrepreneurial spirit when you're
beginning the key thing I think is to
find something to like and to start
liking it it's like buying some
observation that came from come from a
variety of places it can come from
people it can come from the market it
can come from a trend and start to just
apply a curiosity rias mind to unearth
what's going on there and have that
dance between you and it to tell you
what needs to happen this then becomes a
toolkit I would say to help you reality
test certain things so if there is a way
that any of these things can be applied
it can help support that growth so even
just on gross margins if you can collect
your cash upfront versus later that can
have a profound just tactical impact on
your business but it's not the essence
of entrepreneurship these are just
helpful adjustments effectively on the
path thanks Tina yes I love justice but
when I look at all your criteria when
you funded it oh that's a great question
so the question is I love Tesla but if
you look at all of my criteria why would
why would you fund it and so Tesla I
would say and even SpaceX witch dfj
funded and I do need to say that a lot
of that is a testament to Steve
Jurvetson is genius who is the venture
capitalist to champion those investments
at D F J but that's sort of the classic
thing that you would learn in Business
School not to fund because for all the
reasons why you said it's it's hardware
its capital intensive with SpaceX it can
literally blow up so why would you fund
that and I think the idea here is is
that really the genius of Elon Musk is
is that what you see as a car is not a
car and what you see as a rocket is
actually not a rocket and it's a
question of shifting your your your
viewpoint of what that is if you view
Tesla as a car company it is not
something that you would normally fund
but if you view it really as an
autonomous software platform that's
and a data gatherer and idea exactly
that is using this physical instrument
of a car to do that it becomes a totally
different opportunity and company yes I
do
I think anybody has a Tesla probably
sees that as well I think it's because
it's a Tesla is not a car company I
think it is more in my view it is a
profound data gathering an operating
system that gets pretty good so the so
the question is the revenues are linear
so there's a so
so I don't want to go into two minutes
too many details around this but there
is a difference between what's called
willingness to pay an actual
monetization and you know I think this
goes back to this question of well how
do you think about the balance between
monetization and growth and engagement
and sometimes if you try to if you if
you try to focus on monetization at the
wrong time you can win the battle but
lose the war and I think there might be
some of that going on with Tesla's
considerations on things yes in the back
so thank you so much I guess my question
is that a lot of times in like the
startup culture and the value here about
the idea that go necessarily have to be
the first mover a market and you can
just take an existing idea and execute
it far better and so as you know a
season VC that someone who really is
been entrenched in this industry for a
while you talk a little bit more about
what your thoughts are on that idea yeah
so the question is there's this notion
that you don't necessarily have to be
the first mover if there's another idea
if you can be effectively a fast
follower that it can also be a path to
success and some and perhaps it might be
even better and there is the saying that
Trailblazers carry arrows in their back
and and so I I do think that I I think
the the I do think there's multiple
different types of companies if you're
looking at it just purely from a
financial lens that can become successes
but I do think it's important to
understand what your strategy is going
to be so if you are a fast follower I
think you want to be very explicit about
why what you have to believe to believe
that your
to win and what are the lessons that you
can take and learn and then what are the
lessons that you're gonna do to extend
your competitive differentiation so
there's lots of examples of big
companies that weren't the first Google
wasn't the first search engine it was
you know I think at the time there was
over a dozen well-funded search engines
there was a company called Friendster
before before Facebook that wasn't
funded by many of the top funds and so a
lot of the canonical companies that we
look at today actually weren't the first
and I do think there was some virtue in
seeing there is some virtue and in
understanding timing where if you see
that a phenomena is emerging usually
from a venture perspective competition
is validation not something that rules
you out so when if a venture capitalist
will often also ask you who are the
competitors who are the alternatives if
there is a space that is an opening from
a financial perspective there's usually
going to be three companies that will
become significant winners one will
usually go public but be unencumbered
centaur trying to keep their power
position so I do think the important
thing is to identify if there's an
opportunity there is a broader market
opportunity and then to think about if
it's something that you really want to
care about because there is the battle
of getting table stakes with whoever the
front-runner is but that's not going to
win the war what's gonna win the war is
building something that's a long-term
viable concern and that has to come from
something more than just trying to copy
somebody but really trying to extend
where they're at but I do think it can
be a very effective strategy you just
have to be very focused on what you need
to get done to displace them yes so
investments as you've noted aren't
necessarily I can stick up or down can
you talk a little bit about your
involvement in you know unicorn if you
know it has its bumps in the road it's
going up and you know ultimately it's
and investment doesn't work out how you
kind of chosen to step away any measures
you take it wait okay yes happy to do so
the question is can you talk about my
involvement as when when we're backing
unicorns just how that progression
occurs especially if there are speed
bumps around the way or even worse if
there's things that retreat backwards
you know the interesting thing is is
that if you fund a company that becomes
a unicorn oftentimes they're companies
that are become these phenomena that
require the least amount of work
sometimes because they just you're in
these moments of time and space where
things just become they they they grow
phenomenally quickly and in those
moments sometimes the the bigger issues
are around helping the companies or
thinking about how the companies are
going to scale but as a venture
capitalist oftentimes when you're needed
the most is when the companies are in
moments of crisis and so the irony here
is that sometimes the companies that
grow the quickest need the least amount
of help and then usually you get called
in and consumed when there's some
something critically going around the
the cabinet to that I would say is on
strategic transactions that's where your
investors are can be incredibly critical
so I can assure I can tell you that the
strategic transaction of Twitch's
acquisition by Amazon that was a very
and that and I'm not saying that that
was me at all but that was a very
important strategic transaction to get
that right and at those moments a very
helpful board can be very very critical
and and and honestly a lot of your time
is spent when there are those speed
bumps and they happen in so many ways
many times that what happens is
understanding how the companies are
shifting and going through different
phases where the thing that you are
prioritizing before is not the thing
that you need to prioritize in this next
phase so if you're a privatizing growth
before now you have to shift to
monetization or from engagement to
growth understanding those inflection
points I think is where a helpful board
member can really be involved in
shifting the company and then in in in
in very specific strategic transaction
sourcing talent partnerships
acquisitions things like that
that is time I apologize I know that I
want a little bit over but thank you all
this is a this is this is the end of
this season of the entrepreneur thought
leader seminar thank you guys all for
participating and we look forward to
having you back next season